the school with this population such a
small school is made up as fun so here
you go these great size it is
unaffordable okay so like these are my
subgroups these are each of my strata
and you can see it's like only a couple
of which is the biggest great it's
midnight so therefore if I could get a
sample out of here and you can see in
question
wait I want to send them six the kids I
want in this critter six what we'd like
to be the biggest does that make sense
so that the representation here is gonna
be the most logical way to do this is to
plan this out with a table okay so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna say which of
the strata and I look yeah I've got six
I will work my way through each of them
for that particular strata like seven or
actually if we stratas plural for each
of those groups what proportion are they
have got their populations so I'm gonna
say in proportion and then I'm gonna
answer Part A and Part B together read
the movement it says if a stratified
random sample is to be taken on the
basis of these summaries what
proportions should be chosen from each
insert on the ends of this and then Part
B how many students should be chosen if
I want to end up with a group that's
total 60 students okay so I'm gonna say
number of students okay get you
calculator on it because we're gonna
let's start with you seven now there are
125 year sevens right a hundred and
twenty-five see seven out of eight
hundred and fifty-nine right so right
there that actually is the proportion
okay
that's just so I get a sense of that in
my head I'm just gonna give a percentage
because it's nice to be able to UM
graphing with these and that's what
percentages is for so if you just go
ahead and punch in jessamine now I'm
just know he's lovely
have you got that number in my
calculator I want 15%
looks like flying through those students
all to be sevens okay so I'm just gonna
take the same number that's in my
display and I'm going to multiply my 68
okay 50% times the 16 so you can see I'm
gonna get eight point seven carry which
is approximately equal to nine
okay now please it's actually really
important that you'll see why at the end
of this it's quite important that I
right where I'm reading from and where
our students but I wanted to see can you
help me wake up what the risk do those
I'll give you like yeah I reworked these
three three minutes it's pretty easy
nother country work out each of the
proportions and then multiplied by 60 to
get to the number students we have the
whole table will come to them people are
asking questions about rounding here
which is really great I want you to
remember we looked up rounding earlier
okay I'm like right the start of the
year on
and one okay we understood that rounding
was for a purpose like rounding is not
just like some by skill just so that you
can do significant figures it's cause
like when you measure something doable
you can only notice to whatever accuracy
or whatever it might Bend now here we're
rounding but usually careful we're doing
it for a particular purpose now have a
look so why it's important I've got my
job is here right you can see sometimes
I round up sometimes I've had to round
down but think now in total how many
students did I want in my stratified
random sample I wanted in total I wanted
60 all right so now I'm just gonna
quickly check nine ten twelve eleven
nine nine do I end up with 60 students
okay now in this case what do I actually
do he is the reason why somewhat by
chance have a look at the ones that have
rounded up and the ones that are round
down in fact I'll highlight them for you
these ones these ones these ones these
ones these have rounded up do you notice
that and then the other ones have
rounded one two three they've rounded
down okay now like I said white chose
the number of routing ups in the number
any dance has just about balance okay
but that didn't have to be it didn't
have to be it's a little bit like if you
go to the shops right and you do how I
went you buy stuff right and they have
all good prices like this especially if
you could okay now you can imagine right
you can imagine if you add up a whole
bunch of things I thought oh I know it's
okay see both of these prices gonna wrap
down right they're both gonna round down
if I have a series of things that all
round down then the amount I actually
pay at the end is it actually the total
value like it's a little bit less
because every individual thing is
probably because I've had to round and
round and round if some of them are
routing down
more than rounding up I'm actually not
gonna hit number 60 at the end I'm gonna
be short okay
which is why you did have to go back and
say wait a second I'm not going to get
60 I'm really doing at 59 or I could
have the reverse problem and end up with
61 and have to work out well which one
of these groups were I gonna have to
kick somewhat hat off and you look at
how far you had to round okay do you see
how say for example this number here
super close to 10 right so you wouldn't
touch that you wouldn't like with that
which one do you think is round it up or
down furthest so this one is rounded up
and it's rounded up by 0.4 one right so
it's like it's it's almost hard for soon
this is like getting term limits of
reading you know that plus or minus half
of whatever I think so yes it's each one
so if for instance I had too many or too
few that's where change might be ten
does that make sense